نحن نقف الان في هذه الصاله التي يعني
ياتي من خلالها المعتمرون والمسافرون بشكل
عام في هذا الممر ياتي كل تقريبا خمس
دقائق من من اليمين ياتي المسافرون على
الطيران الداخلي ومن اليسار ياتي
المسافرون على الطيران الدولي هذا فيما
يتعلق بالصاله رقم واحد اضافه الى الصلاه
الاخرى في مطار الملك عبد العزيز نتحدث عن
صاله الحجاج وكذلك صار رقم واحد اضافه الى
صاله الاخرى التي تستقبل المعتمرين الصاله
الشماليه على سبيل المثال التي
تحال اليها الطائرات ذات الاشغال العالي
لمنع التزاحم داخل صلاه واروقت المطار
فيما يتعلق خالد كذلك حتى بالطرق التي
والمسارات التي يستطيع من خلالها
المعتمرون الوصول الى مكه المكرمه نتحدث
عن طبعا قطار الحرمين نتحدث كذلك حتى عن
سيارات اضافه الى الحافلات التي يستطيع من
خلالها المعتمرون الوصول الى المسجد
الحرام نشاهد هذه الوفود من المعتمرين
الذين ربما وصلوا من خارج السعوديه حيث
ياتي هؤلاء المعتمرون بشكل مستمر عبر هذه
الصاله يعني اضافه الى ان الاعداد
المتعلقه بالطاقه الاستيعابيه لمطار الملك
عبد العزيز نتحدث عن 11 الف مسافر نتحدث
عن المسافرين والمغادرين والقادمين هذا
هذه هي الطاقه الاستيعابيه اضافه الى 350
350 الف مسافر خلال الفتره السابقه في
الايام الاولى من شهر رمضان هذه
الاحصائيات التي حصلنا عليها والارقام
طبعا فيما يتعلق خالد حتى
بالمجموعات التي تاتي الى مطار جده
المجموعات التي تاتي للعمره كل هذه
المجموعات يتم
احالتها حتى فيما يتعلق
بالصالات الامتعه او المناطق الخاصه
بالامتعه تكون بشكل مستقل حيث كما تعلم
المجموعات كي لا تسبب اي ازدحام في هذه
الصلاه هذه كل التفاصيل المتعلقه بمطار
الملك عبد العزيز خالد من خلال الصلاه
الثلاث الثلاث التي ياتي من خلالها
المعتمرون